hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel and today i'm about to start
playing resident evil village
but because of the embargo i'm only
allowed to show you
20 minutes of the game right now but
this is pretty much gonna be the
beginning
let's do it i think i'll also probably
like upload more content
surrounding the game over the next few
days but for now long ago a young girl
went with her mother to pick berries for
her father
who was hard at work but the forest
greeted them with a dark cold silence
the bushes empty this is interesting yet
determined to find the coraline
the rascal broke free from mother's
grasp and vanished into the trees
mothers worried cries faded fast as the
girl ran on
over vine and under branch and into the
forest deep
this is very pretty eyes upon her the
girl recalled mother's scary bedtime
tales and her throat became bone dry
then the pet lord appeared he greeted
her warm
bat his own wing come child quench your
thirst he said
so she drank oh this is dark blood and
smiled with joy
vampire story passing through the
graveyard menacing storm clouds loomed
and the air turned bitingly cold the
girl was shivering in her thin
clothes then a dark weaver i'm gonna
have to fight somebody he looks like
that
his fingers that's what i think it's
this foreshadowing beautiful
dress come child warm yourself
is this all about ladybug i wonder and
smiled with joy
across waters deep and ominous she went
hoping a boat she found would carry her
home
but hunger's grip tightened and her
heart grew heavy
then the fish came up here more boat
content probably my least favorite part
of resident evil 7 if i'm being
honest eat your fill so the girl ate
and smiled with joy once more
continuing on she soon entered the
forest's dark heart
then an iron steed appeared bearing a
beautiful
golden gear the creature said nothing as
the girl approached
and snatched what she thought was
another gift
ethan's white the horse grew angry and
summoned the other monsters
tara filled the girl's heart
interesting okay not what i expected
very pretty gifts we gave up more you
talk so more in turn is due
in a blink the girl was trapped inside a
mirror
there she's asleep just a peaceful
bedtime story you know
whatever you know kids love that story
is only six months old
woman at the store said it was
traditional
a local tale besides
rose doesn't seem to mind because she
doesn't understand it
thank god i'm on his side i moved here
so that she wouldn't have to deal with
any of that remember
there's nothing wrong with my memory
you're just being paranoid it's not no i
think it's a bit [ __ ] up
i'm sorry but i'm not paranoid i'm just
cautious
then go cautiously take your daughter to
bed
she sucks a bit actually i think is my
review so far
hmm okay it's okay rose
your mother doesn't want to remember it
i can't blame her oh interesting
i wonder so it did when i um
did you say something went through the
settings
it did give me the option to uh
do a like little watch through
explanation of biohazard
just hold my baby open this drawer check
out whatever this is
our taste of music's definitely improved
over the years um i feel like this would
be
pretty confusing if you hadn't
played seven or at least like look
through that stuff what you cook in
um okay it's really dark that's what i
will say
does this web baby sleeps mia makes
everything by hand
so this stuff keeps piling up
i basically can't see and this is just
the part of the house
oh okay cool
this is very dark
my gosh can i can you sleep warm up we
can go for a walk
shut up
that book's too scary for you hmm
okay this is where i would put a baby
maybe oh
that's about right right and there you
go buddy there you go go on
[Laughter]
uh what kind of we got pills here you
trying to get high
so yeah mia really went through some
[ __ ] for anyone who doesn't know
um almost there honey
it was pretty bad uh okay
and yeah i guess now she's uh taking
medication to treat
there you go sweetie i don't know if it
would be ptsd or don't you worry
i'll be right downstairs unsure weird
fairy tale monsters get you but she did
try to kill you
so baby can be cold as hell dude you're
not gonna put blanket on it
all right oh
but tomorrow where are we going tomorrow
three years ago we finally settled down
our new
life in europe and can bring rose up
properly but i still feel like part of
me is trapped in that hell hole back in
louisiana
it was pretty bad i know mia doesn't
like to talk about it but can we really
just forget everything happen
no we can't shouldn't we face what
happened there so we can live our lives
with rose without it hanging around
heads
yes we all heard that much at least i
know mia knows his two she wouldn't have
exploded like that at the hospital if
she didn't care
correct you should definitely address
the absolutely
wild circumstances that befell both of
you i cannot see anything
it's not paranoid it's fine who needs to
be able to see
um okay stairs is back down here
i'm worried she's gonna try and kill me
again because the start of the last game
was very
jump scare murderous of mia
no okay this is good she's still just
she's hanging out
making some food is she okay sleeping
like uh
well like a baby nice because she's a
baby i get it
that smells good what's that oh hands
off mister
it's choba de la gum it's a local recipe
wow you've gone full native haven't you
local wine too but if you're gonna keep
sulking all evening maybe you shouldn't
have any
you really have to stop worrying
it's just finding you in louisiana the
pregnancy
chris moving us here military training
it all happened so fast that's a lot no
well at least we're all together you
me rose now
everything's going seriously i think we
can just forget about it
oh my god what
mia get down what the heck
oh my god
they didn't just murder her they like
they murdered her you know oh
god
i thought she was going to maybe get
kidnapped again chris
what the hell what
no she's dead dude i pro well okay maybe
why is the whole louisiana situation
maybe
he's pretty cute though he's pretty he's
pretty handsome
did not see any of that coming i'll be
honest
well this is pretty look at this
lighting can i go get my child maybe
there's a literal baby upstairs oh
okay i just can't see it okay what the
hell are you doing with my daughter
package secure sir oh take him away
i said get your hands off her maybe
because of the state of her
pregnancy
[Music]
yeah if you haven't played seven you
should
it's all i'm gonna say this would be
very confusing without without context
wow
time to get out of that dark house i
hope it's slightly lighter outside maybe
they'll have lights
maybe it was worth it okay living with
that dark woman
just really like an emo
hey doc
no hello i could have made a case for
her being like hot goth girlfriend
goth girlfriend probably likes being
really dark in the house too
that is cute hey now think positively
all right we talked about this i know
we hardly talk about anything else
i keep telling you it's not rose that
i'm worried about
well then what are you worried about
look
she's gonna be fine i just know it what
else matters
we matter ethan you
matter you just missed me what are you
talking about
is there something you're not telling me
come
none of this seems good for your
relationship buddy um
she is dead now though so sorry for
being insensitive if i'm being honest
okay
this is probably where chris has taken
me
jesus
oh my well
what are you talking about where's chris
redfield
and rose
you just called the phone that was right
next to me i don't think that counts as
a secure channel
[ __ ]
what the hell happened to you oh love
love a flashlight dude
we call those torches in australia which
i recognize is weird because there are
literal torches
um but a flashlight is called a torch
well
maybe i can see something going on
can i take no it's useless
mission objectives eliminate target
recover body correct
secure correct oh well that means that
they probably have the target's body
also
sightseeing for further administration
okay i feel like i feel like i
understand why all this is happening
they're worried that we're infected
right or like that we've been influenced
in some way
um
i don't think ethan was
was really wearing anything that's gonna
protect him in the cold out here though
you know
poor guy he's been through a lot
i don't know that anyone would deserve
any of this and to happen twice
oh my god it's so dark horror games man
i love them but i hate them so much you
know
it's so dark i feel like maybe i should
change the settings a little bit
because of how little i can see uh
display
brightness we gotta turn you up a little
bit it's barely visible now
maybe that's a better barely visible
that's good
eh still just doc but i think that's
just it is outdoors right now i couldn't
see when i was inside either you know
okay i'm gonna follow these tracks it's
only gonna miss ammo out here surely
i'm already worried about my inventory
okay
oh okay i feel like that's
still gonna hurt me okay there we go
well all right ethan i did just say i
felt like it was still gonna hurt you
you didn't
have to whoa what just leaves
okay it's fine
it's so dark
okay cool that's a fun time for
everybody involved
oh god that's blood that's that was a
crook
everybody's just so stoked about all
these dead crows and sounds that are
happening
oh the upside is that it can't make me
sh do any combat right now because i
don't have a weapon
if i had picked up a gun i feel like i
would know i'm in more trouble
why is it always just after i see
something
every time shut up shut up shut up stop
it shut up
shut up why is that music rising
oh i maybe draw attention to drawing
attention where i am it sounds like
somebody killed it oh
oh my oh ethan oh buddy
oh this is a bad time for you did i just
see a footstep
oh god it's so
that dark really that sounds bad ethan
the noises
they seem bad buddy
i just don't really feel like i want to
do anything with any of this
hello i expected there to be a door
there
there's totally someone in there oh this
oh it's a whole house
oh god
it's so dark
what's that what's that what's that what
is it
open oh my god no that shouldn't have
been a cinematic it's resident evil why
was that a cinematic
i'm very suspicious of that we know the
mechanic
why why did you have to lock me into
looking there
oh boy
directional audio oh god oh god oh my
god oh my god
i don't know why i'm speaking quietly
like it's gonna change anything
okay that means a human
probably
i was hoping that i could hide it here
that's probably not gonna work out for
me
okay i would like to leave now
oh my god ethan ethan we need i think we
need to get out
i think that maybe this is all pretty uh
down doesn't seem good here i am making
him do it okay
okay then well oh [ __ ]
it's crazy because um this thought of
what a thing
great yeah no i love that for me
actually
that's um can i do anything no
i'm worried i missed something on that i
can't see any way to interact with it
why are those lights i don't think this
matters that much
is what i'm thinking you know
like the i think that maybe
i need to just let it be
um the start nope i saw that animation
before i heard the noise that really
saved me on that one okay great cool
cool oh
that one didn't scare me ethan buddy can
we hide in here
what wha uh oh uh oh oh
okay
i don't know what happened oh okay
that's interesting
um
i can't see i cannot see a thing
i know a lot of noise just happened
i don't know what caused it it really
sounds like somebody's here you know
just really sounds like somebody's here
and that
i need to get out but i don't know where
to go to get out you know
that's the problem i'm having
am i supposed to go back up is that what
you wanted from me
oh god i think that maybe i did
you know i'm supposed to go back home
yeah
listen oh well
that's a lot's happened okay
son of a [ __ ] um
what i kept trying to say there was that
the start of resident evil 7 was full of
like the worst jump scares in the game
that's not to say that like jack wasn't
really scary or whatever
but the start of it was like
disproportionately jump scary okay so i
was just supposed to go down there and
do nothing and wait for this to happen
and then come back out
what caused all this what did all this i
we agree
you've been similarly confused oh but
i've run out of time
i have to stop playing um this has to be
it i'm not allowed to play anymore so
thank you all for watching the first 20
minutes of
resident evil village uh i hope you
enjoyed it there should be more to come
and i will see you all next time